is there any party that's happy that
pete's finally firing back
that he's like fighting back against
kanye
yeah
yeah i don't know what he said that was
so disrespectful okay all right
yo i i honestly yeah i thought there was
one line of disrespect i thought that
was listen you got three options when a
guy asks where are you you could ignore
his question which is rude you could lie
to him which is really [ __ ] up or you
could just be honest he chose the most
honorable option honesty and in case you
don't believe me here's proof just so
you know i'm honestly so specific you
know what i mean like yeah it's it's
wild but like
it's wild at the same time it's like did
you not think that he's smashing your
wife
like [ __ ] you guys
like we know what time it is okay maybe
i'm biased because i've known this kid
since he was 16. but i feel like he's an
honorable kid he asked me a question i
gave him the most honest answer i could
give him where are you right now he said
right now he didn't say in life
he said right now he wanted specifics
yeah so i tell you where i am right now
i am in bed with your wife
like in fairness kanye did kill him like
two weeks ago in a music video so like
his retaliation i'm like yeah i get it
yeah
what do you think sometimes it's like
a little [ __ ] music video like yeah
but still someone killed he's making
videos too probably
what's the difference here guys
what do you think al i think uh kanye's
just the biggest hypocrite it's like how
you he's been taking shots at pete for
the longest and now he wants to play
victim that pete shoots back and so i i
think it's just really corny of kanye to
go about it that route like like keep
the same energy that you came with so
now pete's talking back like all right
let's take it there now yeah
he's doing exactly what you said he
would do he's skeeting
yeah
well yeah he should take it there
yeah yeah i don't know yeah i guess he
had one thing in the picture is one
thing but i thought he was pretty
reasonable in the rest of the things he
was saying
yeah yeah the rest of his like he was he
was texting like he knew it was going to
be on social media yeah
which you should i think he i think he
was texting like he realized midway
through it was gonna be on social media
like his switch stuff yeah like
he posted it pete posted it like threw
his buddy yeah oh but it wasn't connie
that's why yeah because speed sex are
blue yeah exactly it's pete's like
writing partner that posted on his
instagram oh shout out to dave yeah who
i think it's him i'm not sure exactly
but he basically acts as like an
intermediary between what pete wants to
put out and pete knew that it was gonna
get posted and all his texts are blue
and so he was like very specific to what
he said
and in fairness kanye actually comes off
decent in it too like i don't think he
comes off crazy he's like yeah meet me
here blah blah blah like for kanye he
didn't know it was going to be public
but yet he sounded diplomatic too so
pete put it out yeah yeah
that's also important to know because
it's like of course you're going to put
out
you you you deserve to slap back because
you haven't said anything so you have
every right to clap back
the post said i'm with your wife i'm
posting in bed
completely understandable reasonable
justified
and then you make it look nice with all
the i go through mental health too and
let's help you out blah blah but it
still is marketing right
it's not like i really want to help
is it possible have you ever said some
crazy [ __ ] and then pulled off of it
because you're like i feel bad yeah so
maybe that's just
maybe that's what it
what people are not listening to that
just got cut out of the episode
[Laughter]
but uh but yeah i don't know i think he
said the right thing
and i think it's good uh pr
yeah oh yeah it's good pr it's good pr
for sure i didn't know it came from him
yeah i thought kanye leaked it but
that's right if it's the texas blue
then it's on his side yeah
huh
yeah also doesn't sound crazy so on part
of me is like do they both know this is
going to go out like at what point kind
of sounds like he wants you know pete to
just show up to his event to make a
whole thing out of it yeah that's what
it sounds like it doesn't sound crazy or
not crazy it sounds like he just wants
to continue to buzz like what would be
better than him showing up the sunday
service and them hashing it out there oh
i figured he just wants him to show up
so
he could fight him but he just doesn't
want to do any work to go out of his way
to have to fight a flight number i mean
he leaked where he was staying i
honestly think he would where what in
the text
hhh
yeah pete pete that's that's where
pete's staying there's part you respect
the most after in bed with your wife is
yo here's where i'm staying come see me
man-to-man beverly hills hotel he said
like i'm here yeah come through and then
kanye's like come to sunday service he's
like we don't need all those people
which makes him look like he's down he's
ready to be ready to go even if he's not
leaking those texts makes you look like
you are and then all the disrespect that
you received makes it seem like you're
down to fight or whatever so you look at
him a little bit more like oh [ __ ] hmm
[Music]
i don't know
i could care less there's there's a
after watching half of the kanye dock i
don't know if connie is any different
now than he used to be
you think so i i i honestly i don't know
i think this is just kind of doing kanye
really yeah i think he's very different
than he was yeah
keep in mind this is the kanye
his mom hasn't died yet
what are you done with episode two no i
think i finished episode two i'm into
three a little bit when he was calling
cootie uh chica yeah he's drunk yeah and
he's drunk wild
uh
but like yeah i don't know it just seems
like it seems like you see a flip as
soon as he gets success
yeah like there was a moment and i'm
saying from then to now i don't see much
difference from that midway through
episode three yeah end of episode two
and i haven't i haven't done three yet
because it was weird end of episode two
you see that moment where like he's
successful and then you just it seems
like oh he's he's not he's in history
yet no
no
what now right
remember i said that [ __ ] was mid and
y'all jumped all over me y'all haven't
even finished the [ __ ] thing the
child was stroking like crazy things
y'all haven't even finished the thing i
finished all three we're trying to savor
it
y'all were killing me
because i didn't finish it i thought it
was mid you thought it was some crazy
hot tape
y'all were killing me